mhm war schon klar dass das Bild
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es einen blitzschnelles
Rezept man könnte auch sagen Sallys 5
Minuten es gibt nämlich
zitronenschnitzel das ganze wird mit
Putenschnitzel gleich zubereitet wir
bereiten dazu Nudeln zu und meine Kinder
und ich und ich denke auch Murat mögen
das Gericht sehr gerne denn wir lieben
auch schon zitronenhuhn aus dem Ofen da
gibt's schon ein Rezept auf meinem Kanal
ich zeige euch mal kurz die Zutaten die
ich dafür brauche dafür nehme ich etwas
Olivenöl ich habe ich vier
Putenschnitzel zwei Zitronen davon
brauche ich Saft und Schale eine große
Knoblauchzehe oder zwei kleine
Knoblauchzehen etwas Wasser hier habe
ich 300 ml Milch für die Mehlschwitze
gemüsebrühpaste zum Verfeinern noch Salz
und Pfeffer und später noch ein paar
Kürbiskerne also jetzt wird erst einmal
die Marinade zubereitet dafür gebe ich
Olivenöl in eine große Schüssel die
hoffentlich natürlich ausreichend ist
dann kommt da die Zitronenschale dazu
und die müssen jetzt nicht schreiben
sondern ihr stellt die einfach so ab
damit das Aroma sich gleich damit Aroma
ins Fleisch übergeht und da einfach
drauf achten dass die Schale zum Verzehr
geeignet ist am besten Bio und
ungespritzt
dann den Zitronensaft dazu wenn ihr es
jetzt nicht so sauer zitronig mögt dann
reicht doch eine Zitrone aber ich bin
schon so eine saurig ich mag es gerne
mit viel Zitronensaft und die
Knoblauchzehe die könnt ihr jetzt je
nach Intensität entweder dazu reiben
dazu pressen oder einfach nur halbieren
das ist ein bisschen mit drin liegt und
wenn ihr sagt ihr wollt nicht so den
krassen Knoblauchgeschmack dann echt nur
halbieren und mit dazulegen dann etwas
Salz und Pfeffer dazu
[Musik]
ihr wisst ich pack das später noch mal
Salz rein ne
ich gebe jetzt hier auch noch einen
kleinen bisschen Milch dazu
aber erstmal noch nicht so viel
und das ist jetzt die Marinade fürs
Hähnchen oder für die Putenfilets für
die Putenschnitzel die kommen jetzt hier
rein und dann könnt ihr das ganze
abdecken und dem Kühlschrank eine Stunde
oder zwei durchziehen lassen gerne auch
über Nacht was ich jetzt aber gleich
machen werde ich habe ein Vakuumierer
und ich packe es einfach innen
vakuumierrad denn dadurch entsteht da so
eine Art Druck und die Marinade zieht
sofort ins Fleisch ein und ich kann eben
gleich mit dem Kochen direkt
weitermachen oder was ihr auch tun könnt
wenn es dann einfach gummiert habt dann
könnt das auch noch mal im Kühlschrank
lagern und habe zum Beispiel bereit für
die nächste Grillfeier oder für den
Abend und dann ist es schön ein
vakuumiert luftig hält auch länger und
ihr könnt dann wirklich schön
vorbereiten ich habe hier bei meinem
Vakuumierer diese Beutel mit dabei die
sind auch schön fest und die kann man
dann auch immer wieder benutzen ich
gucke dann immer dass ich oben den Rand
recht schmal vakuumiert dann schneidet
man es ja auf und dann wäscht man es aus
und später kann man es immer wieder
benutzen bis der Beutel sozusagen zu
klein ist und was du
[Musik]
machen ab jetzt geht's eigentlich ganz
schnell denn ihr nehmt jetzt einfach
einen großen Bräter ich nehme jetzt
einfach die Pfanne bisschen Öl rein zum
anbraten und ich habe jetzt hier
parallel schon Wasser angesetzt für die
Nudeln und sobald das Fett dann erhitzt
ist schön scharf anbraten
die Zitronenschale aber nicht mit rein
[Musik]
sobald die erste Seite angebraten ist
einfach wenden dann nehme ich die zwei
Schnitzel raus und brate die restlichen
zwei noch an und die müssen jetzt auch
noch nicht durch sein denn sie kochen
gleich in der Soße nach
dann nehme ich noch mal ein bisschen Öl
und das Mehl mit rein daraus wird jetzt
eine Mehlschwitze gemacht
[Musik]
jetzt nehmt ihr hier einfach noch mal
die Zitronenschale und den Knoblauch das
kommt hier mit rein gerne auch eine
Zwiebel wenn ihr wollt aber ich finde es
der Knoblauch reicht jetzt auch schon
aus gießt das ganze mit der Brühe auf
weil das ist praktisch die Marinade die
übrigen mehlsform auch dazu und das
Wasser wer will kann z.B auch ein
bisschen Weißwein benutzen zum Ablöschen
jetzt noch die gemüsebrühpaste mit rein
und dann den Herd runterschalten
bisschen Salz dazu und gerne in der
Zwischenzeit auch schon mal reden Nudeln
kochen
spätestens danach sagt jetzt jeder das
Essen ist versalzen aber nein ist es
nicht jetzt kocht die Soße auf die
Nudeln sind auch schon im Topf und ich
gebe die Schnitzel einfach wieder zurück
und lasse darin fertiggaren wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr das ganze natürlich
ein bisschen geschmeidiger machen mit
einem Schuss Sahne oder noch ein
Stückchen Butter mit rein wenn jetzt
aber eher leichter halten wollt und sagt
das immer ein leichtes Gericht sein ohne
schwere Soße dann gerne einfach nur mit
Milch zubereiten
[Musik]
also die Soße ist jetzt fertig denn da
kommt jetzt das Hähnchen es fehlt jetzt
sage ich da kommen jetzt die Nudeln
direkt rein mit in die Soße in die
saugen das dann so ein bisschen auf und
dann haben wir in kürzester Zeit ein
richtig schnelles Mittagessen
[Musik]
ich denke schon
denkst du nicht
rein ich lass so ein paar so mit
Olivenöl ja für euch
und wenn ihr wollt gerne so als Crunch
Topping ein bisschen Kürbiskerne hacken
magst du Kürbiskerne drauf nicht da
mache ich gleich bei mir sag mal
probieren
Muffin
du kriegst nichts vom Essen
ja
bin ich halt die böse okay
richtig zart bisschen sauer ja mit
Zitronen
magst du es gerne
okay also das ist eins unserer kurzen
schnellen Mittagsgerichte probiert's
gerne mal aus wenn ihr es nicht so sauer
mögt einfach weniger Zitronensaft was
cremiger mag gibt mehr Sahne dazu aber
an für sich finde ich echt ein tolles
Mittagessen oder Abendessen was eben
nicht so schwer im Magen liegt und
einfach lecker ist und wirklich unserer
ganzen Familie schmeckt also viel Spaß
beim Nachkochen bis zum nächsten Mal und
jetzt können wir uns auch machen
immer gleich deinen Kinder Besteck ja
noch fertig schneiden
[Musik]
Elektroniker nach zitroniger
du bist halt Mamas Tochter ich mag es
nämlich auch gerne richtig zitronig
komm wir nehmen es mit einem Tisch
ja
jetzt bist du eine Zitronenpresse
[Musik]